I believe that Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren are both running really good campaigns
in different ways.
Elizabeth Warren's campaign has been detailed
policy proposals and last week I told you
about Elizabeth Warren's public option for
the Internet proposal along with her ideas
for restoring net neutrality.
We've previously talked about her healthcare
ideas, education, so many others, and she
has been benefiting.
She's been gaining about a point a month for
the last eight months.
She's now taken the second place position
over Bernie Sanders in the 2020 Democratic
primary polls, and I'm going to dig into that
polling data a little bit later.
But what I want to talk about first is that
Elizabeth Warren has put out now a detailed
plan for gun safety regulation.
And it is really good and it addresses a lot
of the things that earlier in the show I mentioned
have been demonstrated to reduce violent homicides
in other countries.
So let's look at it and pay attention to the
legality of all of this stuff because obviously
a lot of gun fetishists won't like what Elizabeth
Warren is proposing, but everything here is
clearly legal, which is what's really great.
So first and foremost, Elizabeth Warren is
proposing to do some things by executive action
and then other things by legislation.
So that's an important distinction.
She is accounting for what can she do with
an executive order at versus what would she
need congressional support to do.
So, background checks for every gun purchase,
uh, by executive action, including at gun
show or online obvious have got to do it.
Uh, apply the 18 plus age restriction that
already exists on more sales.
It does not currently apply to all sales.
Closed what's called the boyfriend loophole,
which there's this reality where abusive spouses
are banned from purchasing firearms in certain
situations but not dating partners.
Uh, and that is what's called the boyfriend
loophole.
It should be closed, prosecuted, unlawful
gun trafficking and investigate the NRA.
She can do this by, by executive action direct
the ATF to revoke gun dealer licenses.
Um, and uh, that is a for violations that
they've already, um, uh, found or that have
already been adjudicated or determined.
Really important that we enforce a lot of
the rules, uh, that we have.
And then Elizabeth Warren also wants to create
a federal licensing system for any gun and
ammunition purchase with the idea of tracking
purchases across state lines and tracking
concerning, uh, gun purchase behavior or patterns.
A one week waiting period, increasing the
minimum age to 21 after the executive action
would increase it to 18 plus.
In all cases.
She wants legislation passed by Congress to
up that to 21 years old, prohibit anyone convicted
of a hate crime from owning a gun, boost the
excise tax on handguns to 30% from 10% and
on ammunition to 50% from 11%.
Chris Rock said this years ago, make the bullets
really expensive.
And that's exactly what Elizabeth Warren is
proposing here.
If you look at studies that look at violence
as a public health issue, they find that we
have a problem that other countries don't
have.
Uh, with regard to gun culture.
And one change alone won't solve this.
It has to be comprehensive.
And what's great about Elizabeth Warren's
proposal is that number one, it attacks a
lot of the different issues surrounding gun
violence in different ways.
But number two, it doesn't violate the first
amendment.
Uh, the Second Amendment, obviously it doesn't
violate the first amendment.
It doesn't focus in just one area.
It's tailored to the problems we have in this
country, uh, other than the cultural ones,
which again are difficult to deal with and
it doesn't violate the second amendment.
Now, all of that being said, and given that
I support this plan, I am concerned that ELAC
totally, this may not be the most advantageous.
Uh, what I mean by that is the left does not
tend to see guns as a voting issue based on
polling.
This isn't my opinion.
The right also doesn't see gun rights as a
voting issue nationally unless a Democrat
is trying to restrict access to guns, in which
case, sometimes people who wouldn't vote it
all will come out to vote and vote for the
republican merely to oppose the gun safety
regulations.
It's disgusting.
It's sick.
But that's the reality.
So I'm behind Elizabeth Warren's plan 110%
here, but I do wonder about the electoral
implications, about focusing too much on this
issue over others merely from an electability
standpoint.
I've spoken with bill share about this in
the past, and I want to hear from you about
that, aside from whether you like this proposal.
And my prediction is a lot of people in my
audience will, uh, what do you think about
the sort of elk Turrell, um, uh, viability
of making this a prominent issue?
Let me know what you think.